next on book TV Henry Louis Gates Blair
Brown Frank McCourt and David McCullough
raid letters from Elizabeth Cady Stanton
Theodore Roosevelt and see Wyeth and
Sexton eff scott Fitzgerald and others
the correspondence is compiled in dura
McCullough Lawson's new book posterity
letters of great Americans to their
children this program lasts about an
hour
oh this is great to be here tonight to
be in this theatre and this company is
exhilarating and memorable in the
extreme we have people here tonight from
New York New Jersey Connecticut main
from Maryland Michigan Texas Wyoming
Colorado California and Arizona and
we're all here because of the power of
the written word and the force of family
in each of our lives and in the lives of
our life of our country when 20 year old
Quentin Roosevelt was fighting in the
First World War his father Theodore
Roosevelt sent him a letter in which he
said right no matter how tired you are
no matter how inconvenient it is right
if you're smashed up in a hospital right
when you were doing your most dangerous
stunts right when your work is most
irksome and disheartening right all the
time right enough letters to allow for
half being lost and right so many of our
great Americans did activists explorers
inventors scientists businesspeople
generals artists musicians writers
doctors and actors they poured
themselves out often their real selves
out on paper and tonight we will hear
from some of our most renowned Americans
in their own words in their own times
seen as they were seen by their own
children through their letters we see
our great Americans as mothers and
fathers in 1994 Henry Louis Gates Jr
published a book about his growing up
years in the 1950s and 1960s in West
Virginia the book began as a series of
letters to his two young daughters
letters written so his girls might
better understand from where and from
whom they had come I'm thrilled to begin
the evening with Henry Louis Gates Jr
himself
thank you very much for the kind
introduction good evening everyone now
in my tradition speaker says good
evening you have to put some feeling
into a good evening everyone all right
you know tend to be black for 30 seconds
and then it's a good experiment you
should do it once a day I did write this
book in the form of letters I was in
Bellagio laga de como the Rockefeller
Foundation Center in the summer of
nineteen ninety-two it was July and I
just completed my first year at Harvard
and it had been a great year
exhilarating year and went to bellagio
ostensibly to do a new edition of the
collected essays of Zora Neale Hurston
and every scholar at the Rockefeller
Foundation Center has her or his own
study and mine was called the vidita
it's a generally it's a self-contained
freestanding structure Peduto in Italian
of course means the view and it's called
the vidita because his great view of the
lakes Lake Como from from the grounds of
this this estate and on the way up on
the very first morning I looked out
across the lake and I saw a man dragging
a boat and boat into water fishing boat
and it just took me back just like that
to a day when my uncle jim my mother's
oldest brother of dying brothers had
taken me fishing in the south branch of
potomac river and i was so exhilarated
that i sat down that road a letter to my
two daughters Maggie was down 24 and
Liza who's 22 and I said I'm sitting in
a study silo shape study called vidita
it was round to it had views on on three
sides plus the door and a circular desk
and I could move my chair around this
circular desk to follow the Sun or to
avoid the Sun as I saw fit and i wrote a
25-page letter that day and I told her
them about the day I went fishing and
then I went on to tell him other things
and the next day I went back and I wrote
a second letter and the letters were
just titled by the
date first was July tenth the second was
July eleventh and by the end of the week
I had about 150 pages and I realized
that I was writing a book and I would
xerox I always write in longhand on
legal pads but mostly and I would Xerox
those and then fedex them back to
Harvard Square my secretary typed them
and then we send them down to my agent
in New York Janklow Nesbitt Lynn Nesbitt
and Tina Bennett and six weeks later
when I came back they said you have a
book and it was in the form of letters
it was the epistolary but Lynn said the
problem is it's written to your
daughter's every letter was written to
my daughters and I said that's right and
she said well how old are they and I
said I don't know 10 and 12 and she said
but this book is full of sex you see I
was writing about my adolescence my
childhood and adolescence and repeating
funny stories that my father had told
and I realized halfway through writing
it then I was grieving for my mother my
mother with whom I was very close it
died in 1992 our died in 1987 this is
1992 so I was trying to recreate this
world that my mother with my mother at
the Center for my daughter's so they
would know this great figure who had
passed and they were too young to know
her but I was by this by the end of the
book I got up to my adolescent and Lynn
said you have to recast this because
it's it's full of sex and I said my
adolescence was not full of sex my
adolescence ladies and gentlemen was
long on desire and short on consummation
but I realized because I was repeating
my father's stories that were a lot of
risk a thing so i had to recast it in
the third person but the only thing that
survived from its initial epistolary
form was the preface and that preface to
colored people i would now like to read
you dear Maggie and Liza I've written to
you because a world into which I was
born a world that nurtured and sustained
me has
mysteriously disappeared my darkest fear
is that Piedmont West Virginia will
cease to exist if some executives on
Park Avenue decide that it's more
profitable to build a completely new
paper mill elsewhere than to overhaul
one a century old Piedmont is a 2,000
people Irish Italian immigrant paper
mill town on the Potomac River now about
three hours west of DC then they will
close it just they did in Cumberland
Maryland with the celanese plant and
Pittsburgh plate glass and the Kelly
Springfield tire company our talent will
die but our people will not move and
they will not be moved because for them
Piedmont West Virginia snuggled between
the Allegheny Mountains and the Potomac
River Valley is life itself I've written
to you because of the day when we were
driving home and you ask your mother in
me just exactly what the civil rights
movement had been all about and I
pointed to a motel on route to that
connects Cambridge with Lexington where
Massachusetts where we were living at
the time and I said that at one time I
couldn't have stayed in that motel your
mother who is white could have stayed
there but your mother couldn't have
stayed there with me and I happened to
look in the rearview mirror on the car
and they looked at each other and rolled
their eyes and you kids looked at us
like we were telling you the biggest lie
that you had ever heard so I thought
about writing this to you I've written
for another reason as well I remember
that once we were walking in Washington
DC heading for the National Zoo and you
asked me if I had known the man to whom
I just spoken and I said no and lies
that you volunteered that you found it
embarrassing that I would speak to a
complete stranger on the street it
called to mind a trip I'd made to
Pittsburgh with my father on the way
from his friend mr. Ozzie Washington
sister's house I heard daddy speak to a
colored man and saw him tip his hat to
the man's wife daddy liked nice hats
caterpillar hats for work dobbs hats for
Sunday it's just something that you do
he said when I asked him if he had known
those people and why had he spoken to
them last summer i sat at a sidewalk
cafe in Italy and three or four
black Italians walked casually by as
well as a dozen or more blacker Africans
each spoke to me rather each nodded his
head slightly or acknowledge me by a
glance ever so subtly when I was growing
up we always did this with each other
passing folks in a sea of white folk yet
there were certain Negroes who would
avoid acknowledging you in this way in
an integrated setting especially if the
two of you were the ones doing the
integrating don't go over there with
those white people if all you're going
to do is Jim Crow yourselves daddy must
have said that to me a thousand times
and by then I think that he meant that
we shouldn't claim to each other out of
habit or fear or use protective
coloration to evade the risks of living
like any other human being or use
clannish pneus as a cop-out for
exploring ourselves and possibly making
new selves forged in the crucible of
integration because your black ass he'd
laugh is integrated already but there
are other reasons that people distrust
the reflex the nod the glance the
murmured greeting one reason is a
resentment of being lumped together with
30 million African Americans whom you
don't know and most of whom you will
never know completely by the accident of
racism we've been bound together with
people with whom we may or may not have
something in common just because we are
black 30 million Americans are black and
30 million is a lot of people one day
you wonder what did the misdeeds of a
Mike Tyson have to do with me so why do
I feel implicated and how could I not
feel racial recrimination when I feel
racial pride then too there were negroes
who were embarrassed even about being
negroes who didn't want to be bothered
with race or with other black people one
of the more painful things about being
colored was being colored in public
around other colored people who were
embarrassed to be coloured and
embarrassed that we both were colored
and in public at the same time as if to
say Negro will you please disappears
that I can get my own white people as if
to say I'm not a Negro like all those
other Negroes as if to say I'm
human being just let me be for much of
my adolescence and adulthood I thought
of these people as having betrayed the
race I used to walk up to them and call
them brother and sister loud and with a
sardonic edge when they look like they
were trying to escape as we put it when
i went off to Yale I would make the
conversion of errant classmates a
serious project a political commitment I
used to reserve my special scorn for
those Negroes who were always being
embarrassed by someone else in the race
someone to dark someone to loud as we
put it someone to wrong as we put it
someone who dared to wear red in public
loud and wrong we used to say that about
each other all the time that [ __ ] is
loud and wrong you see loud carried a
triple meaning speaking too loudly
dressing too loudly and just being too
loudly now I do know that when I was a
boy many negroes would have been the
first accenture other Negroes once they
were admitted into all white
neighborhoods or schools or clubs an
embarrassment to the race phrases of
that sort were frequently bandied about
accordingly many of us in our generation
engaged in the strangest antics to flout
those strictures like eating watermelon
in public eating it loudly and merrily
and spitting the seeds into the middle
of the street red juice running down the
sides of our cheeks collecting under our
chins or taking the greatest pride in
what we call the Royal kink kinky hair
of the afro my Uncle Harry was a
Methodist minister who had gone away
when I was a boy to Boston my Uncle
Harry used to say what he came back from
Boston that he didn't like watermelon
which I knew was a lie because I used to
see him wolf down slices of watermelon
when I was a little kid before he went
off to seminary at Boston University but
Uncle Harry came around just like he
came around to painting God and Jesus
black and all the Seraphim and the
cherub m2 and I from another direction
have gradually come around also and
stopped trying to tell other Negroes how
to be black girls do you remember when
your mother and I woke you up early on a
Sunday morning just to watch Nelson
Mandela walk out of prison and how it
took a couple of hours for Mandela
emerged and how you both wanted to go
back to bed and then when that didn't
work to watch cartoons instead and how
we began to worry that something bad had
happened to Mandela on the way out of
that prison because the delay had been
so long and when he finally walked out
of that prison how we were so excited
and teary eyed at Mandela's nobility his
princeliness his straight back his
unbowed head I think I felt that their
walked the Negro as my daddy might have
said their walked the whole of the
African people as regal as any King in
that feeling I had that gooseflesh sense
of identity that I felt at seeing Nelson
Mandela or listening to Mahalia Jackson
sing or watching Muhammad Ali fight or
hearing dr. King speak is part of what i
mean by being colored i realized the
sediment may not be logical but i want
to have my cake and eat it too which is
why i still nod or speak to black people
on the streets and why it felt so good
to be acknowledged by those afro
Italians who pass my table at that cafe
in Milan I want to be able to take
special pride in a Jesse Norman aria a
Muhammad Ali shuffle a Michael Jordan
slam dunk a spike lee movie a Thurgood
Marshall legal opinion a Toni Morrison
novel James Brown's James Brown doing
the camel walk above all else I enjoy
the unselfconscious moments of a shared
cultural intimacy whatever form they
take when no one else is watching when
no white people are around like Joe
Louis's fights which my father still
talks about as part of the fixed
repertoire of stories that texture our
lives you've seen his eyes shining girls
as he describes how Joe Louis hit max
smelling so many times and so hard in
the second fight and how some reporter
had asked him after the fight Joe what
would you have done if that last punch
had not smelling out and how old Joe had
responded without missing a beat I don't
run around behind him to see what was
holding him up even so I ravel up the
notion that I can't be part of other
groups that I can't construct identities
through elective affinity that race must
be the most important thing about me is
that what I one of my
gravestone here lies in african-american
so I'm divided I want to be black to
know black to luxuriate in whatever I
might be calling blackness at any
particular time but to do so in order to
come out the other side to experience a
humanity that it is that is neither
colorless no reducible to color Bach and
James Brown sushi and fried catfish part
of me admires those people who can say
with a straight face that they have
transcended any attachment to a
particular community or group but I
always wanted to run around behind them
to see what's holding them up I am not
every Negro I'm not native to the great
black metropolis as New York Chicago or
Los Angeles say nor can I claim to be a
citizen of the world i am from and of a
time and place piedmont west virginia
and that's a world apart a world of
difference so this is not a story of a
race but a story of a village a family
and its friends and of a sort of
segregated peace what hurt me most about
the glorious black awakening of the late
60s and early 70s is that we lost our
sense of humor many of us thought that
enlightened politics excluded it in your
lifetimes girls I suspect you will go
from being african-americans to people
of color to being once again colored
people actually if I writing this today
I would probably add neo-newbie ins I
don't mind any of the names of myself
but I have to confess did I like colored
best maybe because when I hear that word
I hear it in my mother's voice and in
the sepia tones of my childhood as
artlessly and as honestly as I can I
have tried to evoke a colored world of
the 50s a Negro world of the early 60s
and the advent of a black world of the
later 60s from the point of view of the
boy that I was when you were old enough
to read what follows girls I hope that
it brings you even a small measure of
understanding at long last of why we see
the world with such different eyes and
why that is for me
a source both of gladness and of regret
and I hope you'll finally understand why
I continue to speak to colored people
that I pass on the streets love daddy
you may never be wives mothers or
housekeepers explained Elizabeth Cady
Stanton to her 19th century audiences
but you will be women for 54 years
Elizabeth Cady Stanton fought vehemently
for overall social justice for women she
organized meetings and wrote speeches
and for eight months of each year during
the 1870s she toured the country
lecturing spreading the word and earning
a living Stanton delivered one speech a
day and two on Sundays in town after
town Blair Brown will read Stanton's
letter to her 20 year old daughter in
which she describes a day on the road to
margaret l stanton austin minnesota
december first 1872 dear Maj imagine me
today sitting in a small comfortable
room in the railroad hotel about a half
mile from this little Minnesota town
where I do not know one soul but as
everybody is polite and attentive I
suppose they all know me I spoke last
evening at Waterloo and in order to
reach here my next place I was obliged
to leave at midnight so after my lecture
I had an oyster supper packed up my
finery and all ready to start took a
short nap on the sofa I was called it
too but as the horses were sick and I
was the only guest going from the hotel
westward I was toted I and my baggage in
a little cart drawn by a mule through a
fearful snowstorm the wind cutting like
particles of glass having arrived safely
at the depot my escort a good-natured
overgrown boy deposited me and mine
beside a red-hot stove learning then and
there that the train was two hours
behind I rolled my cloak up for a pillow
laid down on the bench and went to sleep
listening to a discussion in an
adjoining room on the merits of my
lecture one man vowed in a broad Irish
brogue that he would leave the country
if the women voted well gracious i
thought to myself
as I dozed into slumber what would
become of our experiment if one white
male should desert the flag in due time
I was waked by some gentle Patrick
perhaps my very critic tickets bought
veliz checked and I transferred to a
sleeping car we're in a twinkling I at
once flopped asleep again without even
taking my bonnet off at eight I was
roused by an African for this place
where it being Sunday the train lies
over so i ordered a fire washed my face
ate breakfast undressed regularly went
to bed and slept soundly until one when
i arose took a sponge bath had dinner
read all the papers i could procure and
now sit down to answer your letter which
was the only one i received at Waterloo
I read it alone at midnight and though I
am always advising you to write short
letters I did wish this time you had
written more at length you asked if it
is not lonely travelling as I do it is
indeed and I should have enjoyed above
all things having Hattie with me but you
see dearest that would double my
expenses and as I am desirous of making
money for the household I must practice
economy in some direction and above all
considerations of loneliness and fatigue
I feel that I am doing an immense amount
of good in rousing women to thought and
inspiring them with new hope and self
respect that I am making the path
smoother for you and Haddie and all the
other dear girls you would laugh to see
how everywhere the girls flock around me
for a kiss a curl an autograph they all
like so much my lecture the coming girl
I am so glad there is to know that you
are happy now improve every hour and
every opportunity and fit yourself for a
good teacher or professor so that you
can have money of your own and not be
obliged to depend on any man for every
breath you breathe the helpless
dependence of women generally makes them
narrow Diskin
tented the beings they are so many are
with much love for yourself kind regards
for your chums and pleasant dreams for
all in vassar good night mother
in 1969 psychologically unstable poet
and Sexton was of her professional peak
for the first time a play she had
written was to be staged off-broadway
she was so sought after and well-paid
performer reading her poetry for
audiences around the country and her
latest book livered I was about to win
the Pulitzer Prize it seemed to that her
suicidal fantasies were being held at
bay here five years before her final day
and Sexton writes to her 15 year old
daughter Linda april nineteen sixty-nine
Wednesday 245 p.m. dear Linda I am in
the middle of a flight to st. Louis to
give a reading I was reading a New
Yorker story that made me think of my
mother and all alone in the seat I
whispered to her I know mother I know
found a pen and I thought of you someday
flying somewhere all alone and me dead
perhaps and you wishing to speak to me
and I want to speak back at Linda maybe
it won't be flying maybe it will be at
your own kitchen table drinking tea some
afternoon when you are 40 anytime I want
to say back first I love you too you
never let me down three I know I was
there once i too was 40 with a dead
mother who I needed still this is my
message to the 40 year old Linda no
matter what happens you were always my
bubble link my special Linda gray life
is not easy it is awfully lonely I know
that now you to know it wherever you are
Linda talking to me but I've had a good
life I wrote unhappy but I lived to the
hilt you too Linda lived to the hilt to
the top
I love you forty-year-old Linda and I
love what you do what you find what you
are be your own woman belong to those
you love talk to my poems and talk to
your heart I'm in both if you need me
I'll I'd Linda I did love my mother and
she loved me she never held me but I
miss her so that I have to deny I ever
loved her or she me silly and so there
xoxoxo mom
in 1875 landscape architect Frederick
Law Olmsted wrote to his four-year-old
son Henry Henry was away from New York
for the summer and was having trouble
with a cow that was getting into some
rhubarb he asked his father to send the
family dog quiz to help we have Frank
McCourt with Olmsted response may May
thirteenth 1875 dear Henry the cats keep
coming into the yard six of them every
day and quiz drives them out if I should
send quiz to you to drive the calls away
from your rhubarb he would not be here
to drive the cats out of the art if six
cats should keep coming into the yard
every day and not go out in a week there
would be 42 of them and in a month 180
and before you come back next November
1260 then if there should be 1260 cats
in the yard before next November half of
them at least would have been would have
kittens and if half of them should have
six kittens apiece there would be more
than five thousand cats and kittens in
the yard there would not be any place
for Rosanna to spread the clothes unless
she drove them all off the green plot
and if she did they'd have to crowd at
the end of the yard near as the house
and if they did that they'd make a great
pile as high as the top of my windows a
pile of five thousand cats and kittens
some of them black ones in front of my
window would make my office so dark I
should not be up to write in it besides
that those underneath particularly the
kittens would be hurt by those standing
on top of them and I expect they would
make such a great squalling all the time
that I should not be able to sleep if I
was not able to sleep I should not be
able to work but did not work I should
not have any money and if i had not any
money i could not send any to plymouth
to pay your fare back in the fall river
and I could not pay my fare to go to
Plymouth and so you and I would never
see each other anymore no sir I can
spare quiz and you would have to watch
for the cows and drive them off yourself
or you will raise no rhubarb your
affection father
in July of 1938 eff scott Fitzgerald was
41 years old five years had passed since
his last last novel was published and he
was having trouble financially so he
took a job writing screenplays in
Hollywood his wife Zelda
institutionalized for schizophrenia felt
the responsibility with his wife Zelda
institutionalized for schizophrenia he
felt the responsibility of raising their
daughter Scotty was his alone the
following letter was written to 16 year
old Scotty after a series of episodes of
bad behavior july seven 1938 dear scotty
i don't think i'd be writing letters
many more years and i wish you would
read this letter twice bitter as it may
seem you'll reject it now but a later
period some of it may come back to you
as truth when I'm talking to you you
think of me as an older person and
authority and when I speak of my youth
what I say becomes unreal to you for the
young can't believe in the youth of
their fathers but perhaps this little
bit would be understandable if I put it
in writing When I was your age I live
with a great dream the dream grew and I
learned how to speak of it make people
listen then the dream divided in one day
when I decided to marry your mother
after all even though I knew she was
spoiled and meant no good to make I was
sorry immediately I married her but
being patient in those days made the
best of it and got to love her in
another way you came along and for a
long time we make quite a lot of
happiness out of our lives but I was a
man divided she wanted me to work too
much for her and not enough for my dream
she realized too late that work was
dignity and the only dignity and tried
to atone for it by working herself but
it was too late and she broke and is
broken forever it was too late for me to
recoup the damage I'd spent most of my
resources spiritual and material on her
but I struggled on for five years on to
my
collapse and all I cared about was
drinking and forget it the mistake I
made was in marrying her we belong to
different worlds she might have been
happy with a kind simple nine in a
southern garden she didn't have the
strength of the big stage sometimes she
pretended and she pretended beautifully
but she didn't have it she was soft when
she should have been hard and hard when
she should have been yielding she never
knew how to use her energy she passed
that failing on to you for a long time I
hate her her mother forgiving her
nothing in the line of good habit
nothing but getting by and conceit I
never wanted to see again in this war
women who were brought up as idlers and
one of my chief desires in life was to
keep you from being that kind of person
one who brings ruin to themselves and
others when you begin to show the
starving signs at about 14 I comforted
myself with the idea that you were too
precocious socially and a strict school
with fix things but sometimes I think
that idlers seemed to be a special class
for whom nothing can be planned plead as
one will with them they're only
contribution to the human family is to
warm a seat at the common table my
reforming days are over and if you're
that way I don't want to change you but
I don't want to be upset by idlers
inside my family or out I want my energy
and my earnings for people who talk my
language I've begun to fear that you
don't you don't realize that what I am
doing here is the last tired effort of a
man who once did something finer and
better there's not enough energy or call
it money to carry anyone who's dead
weight and I'm angry and resentful in my
soul when I feel I'm doing this people
like Rosalind that your mother must be
carried because the illness makes them
useless what's a different story that
you have spent two years doing no use
for work at all improving neither your
body nor your mind but only writing
reams and reams of dreary letters too
dreary people with no possible object
except obtaining
invitations which you could not accept
those letters go on non even in your
sleep so that I know your whole trip now
is one long waiting for the post it's
like an old gossip who can still her
tongue you've reached the age when one
is of interest to an adult only insofar
as one seems to have a future the mind
of a little child is fascinating for it
looks at all things with new eyes but at
about 12 this changes the adolescent
offers nothing can do nothing say
nothing that the adult cannot do better
living with you in Baltimore more you've
told Harold that I alternated between
strictness and neglect by which I
suppose you mean the times I was so
inconsiderate as to have TB authoress I
retiring to myself to write for had
little social life apart from you Reza
represented a rather to domestic duty
forced on me by your mother's illness
but I endured your top hats and
telephones until the day you snub be at
dancing school less willingly after that
they began to be an unsympathetic site
to you that alienated first mrs. Owens
then your teachers had bring more the
line of those who felt it runs pretty
close to you adults who saw you every
day among them you've made scarcely a
single close friend with all your
mastery of exterior art of friendliness
all of them have loved you as I do but
all of them have had reservations and
important ones that felt that something
in you wasn't willing to pull your way
to do your part for more than an hour
this last year was a succession of
information beginning as far back as
December that you were being unfair to
me more frankly that you were cheating
the misfortune about your standing in
your class the failure to children at
the overs at Christmas the unwillingness
to help with your mother at Easter in
golf or tennis then the dingy outbreak
in the infirmary at the people who were
on to you who knew you had none of the
scholar in you but lived in a baby
stream of the dance
of a provincial school finally the
catastrophe which as far as I'm able to
determine had no effect except to scare
you because you knew I wouldn't maintain
you in the East without some purpose or
reason if you did not have a charm and
companion ability such a blow might have
chasing you but unlike my film my Uncle
Phil who will always be able to find
companions who will reassure you of your
importance even though your
accomplishment is a goose egg to the
last day of his life phil was a happy
man though he loved always and
dissipated a quarter of a million of his
own and his sister's money and left his
wife in poverty and his son as you saw
him he had charm great charm he never
liked me after I was grown because once
he lost his charm in front of me and I
kicked his fat backside your charm must
not have been in evidence on the day
mrs. Perry Smith figuratively did the
same to you all this was the long
preparation for the despair I
experienced ten days ago that you did or
did not know how I felt about Baltimore
that you thought I reprove of your
meeting a boy and driving back with him
on chaperone to New York by night that
you honestly thought I have permitted it
permitted that will tell it to harold
who seems to be more gullible the clerk
from the garden of Allah walked me up
with the telegram which I mistook
Simmons for Finney and I called the
Finney's to find them gone the result
was entirely a situation of your own
making if you're any real or great about
the Walker episode you'd have respected
my wishes for a single week to sum up
what you've done to please me or make me
proud is practically negligible since
the time you made yourself a good diver
at camp and now you're softer than
you've ever been in your career is a
wild society girl vintage 1925 I'm not
interested I don't want any of it it
would bore me like dining with the Ritz
brothers when I do not feel you're going
somewhere your company tends to depress
me for the silly waste and triviality in
volved on the other hand when
occasionally I see signs of life an
intention of you there's no company in
the wall I prefer but there's no doubt
you have something in your belly some
real gosta for life a real dream of your
own and my idea was to wait it to
something solid before it was too late
as it was too late for your mother to
learn anything when she got around to it
once when you spoke French as a child it
was enchanting with your odd bits of
knowledge now your conversation is as
commonplace as if you spent the last two
years in the corn hall or high school
that you saw in life and read in sexy
romances I shall call me since sep
tember to meet your ball but this letter
is a declaration that I'm no longer
interested in your promissory notes but
only in what I see I love you always but
I'm only interested by people who think
and work as I do and it isn't likely
that i shall change at my age whether
you will i want to remains to be seen
daddy PS if you keep the diary please
don't let it be the dry stuff i could
buy in a 10 Frank guidebook I'm not
interested in dates and places even the
Battle of New Orleans unless you have
some unusual reaction to them don't try
to be witty in the writing unless it's
natural just true and real PPS will you
please read this letter a second time i
wrote it over twice
when Theodore Roosevelt was a child
frail and asthmatic his father told him
you have the mind but you have not the
body and without the help of the body
the mind cannot go as far as it should
you must make your body as an adult
Roosevelt would try anything horseback
riding wrestling football tennis and his
famous scrambles through rock creek park
tonight we have David makalah's reading
the words of the President wiley's
president
the White House March 5th 1904 dear
Kermit I am wrestling with two Japanese
wrestlers three times a week I am NOT
the age or the build one would think to
be World likely over an opponent's head
and batted down on a mattress without
damage but they are so skillful that I
have not been hurt at all my throat is a
little sore because once when one of
them had a stranglehold i also got hold
of his windpipe and thought i could
perhaps choke him off before he could
choke me however he got ahead your
loving father theodore roosevelt the
white house april 9th 1904 dear ted i am
very glad i've been doing this Japanese
wrestling but when I am through with it
this time I'm not sure i will ever try
it again while i'm so busy with other
work as i am now often by the time i get
to five o'clock in the afternoon i will
be feeling like a stewed owl after an
eight hours grapple with senators
congressmen and they'll and alike then i
find arrest the wrestling a trifle too
vehement for me arrest my right ankle
and my left wrist and one thumb and both
great toes are swollen sufficiently to
more or less impair their usefulness and
i am well mottled with bruises elsewhere
still I've made good progress and since
you left they've taught me three new
throws that are perfect corkers
lyricist playwright director and
producer Oscar Hammerstein felt that to
be a good man was the best any father
could do for his children in 1953 Oscar
Hammerstein was 57 years old he had
already seen brilliantly successful
plays with showboat Oklahoma South
Pacific and the King and I the sound of
music was still years ahead in his
future Hammerstein wrote the following
letter as an installment in an unusual
series of autobiographical letters for
his eldest son bill New York January
18th 1953 dear bill I've just started to
read Carl Sandburg's autobiography of
the first 21 years of his life always
the young strangers I cannot help
contrasting it with these haphazard
memories I am giving you his life starts
a little earlier than mine in a small
town Galesburg Illinois and how simple
and pure and orderly it seems compared
to mine he was the son of a poor but
industrious Swedish carpenter it was a
good clean orderly family life they all
led he and his mother and father and
eight other children they seemed never
to have wanted for meals or shelter but
they all had to work pretty hard at one
chore or another a political parade was
a big event to be seen and cherished
Carl Sandburg built his experiences
slowly but solidly into a philosophy and
a talent for expressing his philosophy
whatever order or form I have got out of
life has been extracted from chaos this
was true when I was a child and is true
now the farm and my determination to be
down here as often and for as long a
time as possible expresses my eagerness
for peace and systematic living as far
back as I can remember I always wanted
to live in the country even in the city
if I saw an empty lot with a few weeds
and a tree in it
was attracted by it in your first year
we took a small cottage in far rockaway
in a street jammed with cottages but
just across the street was a tall tree
and I used to sit on the small porch and
look across at that tree against the sky
as the light was fading in the evening
and it gave me a great feeling of peace
and even happiness and it made me
thoughtful about life in the abstract as
I sometimes get thoughtful listening to
a symphony without really hearing it I
remember telling Walter riddle about
this feeling and he used to kid me about
the tree for a long time it became a
symbol to him of my naive idealism a
psychologist would be skeptical of my
professed groping for peace he would say
why don't you take it you've enough
copyrights to live on why don't you stop
working why don't you leave the hectic
life of New York and the theater live in
Doylestown take care of your cows and
have the piece you've always been after
these would be hard questions to answer
I often think of doing this someday then
I ask myself what would you do when the
kiwanis task you to come down and speak
to them if you read an editorial in the
Intelligencer which made you angry would
you not use your new leisure to sit down
and write them a hot letter of protest
would you not in a few years become as
involved with as many friends and as
many projects in and around bucks county
as you are now in New York and would you
have any more freedom as a big fish in a
small pond and you have as a
medium-sized fish in a metropolitan bond
I suppose I would not have more freedom
not at my present age anyway I suppose
you get free of these things when you
get so old and feeble that you say that
they say don't ask him to do that he's
an old man and he hasn't been very well
sometimes I see myself as a lean and
slippered Pantaloon with white hair
wearing tweeds who's cut has become out
of date sitting on a porch watching the
younger people playing tennis and
receiving my sons and daughters when
that
come when they come to visit me and
listening to them tell me of their
doings in the great world outside if
this is the stage I must get to before I
find peace and the order is orderly and
systematic life then the whole idea is
very discouraging using the word peace
makes me rush to confess that a peace
means peace of mind I have this to an
amazing degree compared to all the other
people i know i have always had this
somehow i have never been harried or
extremely worried except for temporary
specific causes in a confused world I am
confused but I am NOT thrown into a
panic by confusion I am not unduly
distressed by it I can take confusion
and imperfection in my stride all this
brings me back to where we left off my
childhood it is possible that there were
many lucky accidents in my upbringing
that were good for me my strange
disorderly unsystematic family may have
developed in mia tolerance for disorder
which makes it possible for me to live
in a disorderly world even though i
crave another kind but there is no other
kind the world is very much like my
family filled with people of unharness
passions illogical impulses inconsistent
religions and clashing philosophies all
these whirling atoms are held together
loosely and kept going slowly in the
same general direction by one element
love you may substitute another word for
this if you please you may call it God
or you may call it goodness you may call
it seventh day adventism or Freemasonry
or democracy or communism or the
American Legion or the Doylestown sewing
circle or local 802 but it is the desire
to be with a group of other people all
working with one another in an effort to
do something which all consider a good
thing to do what one group considers a
good thing to do maybe thought the worst
thing in the world by another group but
if you don't belong to
group that is doing something or thinks
it is doing something you haven't a
chance within that group is the
justification of that small atom that is
you and someday you hope to do something
very fine which will make the group
applaud you the biggest and truest and
most significant line in all nursery
rhymes is a line in little Jack Horner
what a good boy am i that is what
everybody wants to say to himself but he
can have little assurance of his belief
unless it is endorsed by other members
of the group everyone has this desire
for approval the trouble is that many
people do not work hard enough to get it
then they become unhappy paranoid
clinging for the life of their egos to
their own self approval and blaming the
rest of the world for not endorsing it
this whole essay Springs from what I've
been telling you about my family and
what I'm going to tell you about them in
the light of the earnest and scientific
approach that all young people of your
generation bring to the task of bearing
and breeding and educating your young my
family and many families of that day
indeed many families of today seem like
irresponsible maniacs but all the
science in the world is no good without
this thing I have quickly and carelessly
called love there must be love
unselfconscious spontaneous and
unscientific shining out of all the
dusty corners of the disorderly
household and specifically the little
Adam whirling around among billions of
other atoms very like himself must be
given the illusion that they are not so
like himself that he is something very
special worth promoting worth perfecting
worth building up to that position of
prominence and achievement where he can
lie in his bed
or stand on a hill or walk down the
street and say to himself with
conviction what a good boy am I
the artist NC wats enthusiasm for the
world around him was apparent and nearly
all he did he encouraged his five gifted
children to stretch their imaginations
and creativity to the fullest three of
his children on react Caroline and
Andrew became artists his daughter and a
composer and painter and son at an
engineer and inventor Wyeth was an
exceptional letter writer who guided and
challenged his children and made certain
that life for them was full of wonder
imagination principle and productivity
we will end the evening tonight with a
letter from NC Wyeth to his son the
brilliant painter Andrew Wyeth reading
the letter will be Andrew Wyeth son NC
Wyeth grandson jamie wyeth it is
especially fitting in a hopeful
conclusion to have mr. Wyeth read as he
is a third generation of American
greatness and a painter who through his
work has heeded his grandfather's advice
I'm honored to present my friend jamie
wyeth
I thought I'd preface this letter to
describe this set this thing up a bit
with me I was born a year before my
grandfather was killed at age 60 and so
I never knew him growing up though his
studio was physically higher in the hill
above our family's house and i would
spend endless afternoon's going through
this incredible studio full of costumes
and cutlasses from Treasure Island and
blunderbusses for various books and so
forth and and then I would go in the
back of the studio and there were stacks
of his illustrations from all the
wonderful books that still have
resonance today with readers and so
forth them and I wanted to bring up the
resonance and particularly illustrates a
resonance I a few years ago the New York
Public Library which has the collection
of all his Robin Hood series and
Stephenson's kidnapped and they just had
restored them put them back into better
shape and so they were having sort of a
an opening to reap resent the paintings
and they invited me to come up I was 25
at the time I think her 30 and so they
were having his nice party and whatnot
and I was standing there and I felt this
sort of tug in my arm and I looked down
and here was this little old lady she
must have been I don't lady is there
early 90s and I said hello and she said
oh mr. Wyeth I am so thrilled to meet
you as a child I grew up with your
illustrations
either thought the Fountain of Youth was
in Chadds Ford but anyway this letter is
from written in his studio in Chadds
Ford Pennsylvania februari 16th 1944
dear andy there's a slow bill we win
coming down the valley comes in great
round intermittent puffs and piles up
about the studio ever so like some
engulfing and visible surf one can
almost hear it pouring off the back roof
cascades a spoon spending itself in
foaming at ease among the orchard trees
and tangled grass the day is somber and
gray and I'm a reminded of throw who
found the drab days of winter so
inspiring these dreary winter colors
which depressed other people suggested
to him the highest spiritual traits that
constituted his concept of beauty the
week has been to me a singular mix of
ineffable sadness and inspiration to
moods that often happen together but
there is a persistent melancholy which
I'm unable to shake off to circumvent
these feelings I've devoted most of my
spare time to reading especially at
night when sleep eludes me throw Goethe
Emerson Tolstoy all had struck me as
always with incisive vitality and
freshness my ruminations have again been
vividly stirred these great men forever
radiate a sharp sense of that profound
requirement of the artist to fully
understand that consequences of what he
creates are unimportant let the motive
for action be in the action itself not
in the event I know from my own
experience that when I create with any
degree of strength and beauty I have no
thought of consequences anyone who
creates for effect to score a hit does
not know what he is missing this period
of unprecedented distractions and over
stimulation constitutes a fierce
antagonist to the compliments
compliments of the spirit whatever is
worth discovering one's heart and mind
can only rise as a surface among quiet
conditions which one thought grows
besides another and one has time to
reflect periods of bleak thinking and
all steer feeling that kind of cuts to
the bone are imperative spiritual
experiences which so often masquerade
for cultural influences are so often
merely cozy and sociable I was struck
with a quotation from Michelangelo it is
only well with me when I have chisel in
my hand how stimulating is a company of
generous minds I'm thinking of the four
masters named above who overlooked
rifles and keep their minds
instinctively fixed on whatever is good
and positive in the world about them
true magnanimous people have no vanity
no jealousy they have no reserves
they're fed on the true and solid
wherever they find it what is more they
find it everywhere there's little doubt
that the modern line is opposed to the
romantic mind the modern mine is mainly
content to ask and seek causes and
consequences whereas a romantic mine
seeks the significance of things the
romantic mind must be restored to his
necessary place of leadership if things
have no significance things are Hollow
the greats in all the arts have been
primarily romanticists in realest the
two cannot be separated they interpreted
life as they saw it but through every
lines being soaked in the consciousness
of the object when is bound to feel
beside life as it is the life that ought
to be and is that the captivates us all
great painting is something that
enriches and enhances life something
that makes it higher wider and deeper a
great painter is a great man painting
sound feeling can only exist in a man
who is living on all sides of life that
is natural damn an only through this
experience can he sense his times and
avoid that ever lurking pit full of
egocentrism someone uncommon ly wise
said nothing is so poor in melancholia
as art that is interested in itself and
not in its subject to live to keep one's
eyes open and wonder to be surprised by
things here's a quote which I think will
interest you great painting like box
music and texture closely woven subdued
like the early go blend tapestries no
emphasis
climax is no beginnings or endings
merely resumption xand transitions it
designs so sustain that there is no
effort in the starting and every casual
statement is equally great but of course
such depth presupposes another mode of
feeling one has to be a Bach before one
can paint in his power and richness that
the style can only spring from a Deeping
of our emotional life that is what we
really demand and look for there's a
real task on our hands Andy modern art
critics and their supine followers like
the flat and the shower they like it as
they like soft drinks and factory made
bread intensity distinction fire those
elements of mature sincerity these they
love they fear disturbance miles very
well we all are remember me to everybody
warmly and give little Nicholas a
special pad for me he then adds a PS
Monday 730am then reading this over I'm
impressed by the fact that none of the
thoughts expressed or new to you we have
together gone over these matters again
and again but as good I think to repeat
fundamental truths and if possible bring
them into new and fresh focus a great
truth is like a mountain that one walks
around and the changes of its contours
one moves his position only emphasize
Andhra vivify its majesty
thank you all so much for coming and
thank you all for your wonderful
readings thanks
posterity is dori mccullough Lawson's
first book for more information visit
the publishers website at Random House
calm / doubleday